So the other day my friend and I were walking down the street
when all of a sudden we heard
"Hey mama!"  You lookin' real fine, baby."
We both immediately turned around and said:
"Hey!  That is not nice!  That does not make me feel safe."
"What would your mother say?"
Whenever I discuss Catcalling with my male-friends
I'm often met with the same kind of response.
Aw, dude!  That's a sick compliment.
Honestly, I'd be flattered by that!
Yeah, but...it doesn't happen that often right?
And when I discuss Catcalling with my female-friends
we have the same kind of reaction.
"Ugh!  I hate it.  It's like how do you want me to react?"
It's so scary...I don't know you.
I don't know what you're going to do.
You know, that's why I always carry weapons.
No matter what.
It was kind of scary how many of us had stories
about strange men following us around or catcallers
who wouldn't stop when you asked them to.
And this whole thing made me start thinking
what is the appropriate response to this?
Is it sarcasm?
(whistling)
Yes!  Finally, a man who wants to fuck me.
(ding!)
You know, I've been walking down the street for so long
just waiting for someone to tell me that.
So.  You wanna...have sex?
Oh!  Hell yea baby!
Baby?  Woah.  No no no.  calm down.  I don't even know you.
I don't even know if you're husband material.
What!?  No!
Should I act grateful for this attention?
(gasps)
Thank you so much!
I'm so flattered that you find my genetics physically attractive!
I actually didn't have anything to do with it.
Let me call the real heroes so you can thank them
they'll get a kick out of it--one second.
Hi guys!  I have someone here who wants to say something to you.
Here you go!
These are the people you want to compliment.
He-hello?
Or maybe I should try to give them a taste of their own medicine.
You lookin' real fine baby!
Hey boy!  Give me your dick!
(gasps)
I said give me your dick.  Right now.
No!  No--anything but my dick!
Look, I know it's not just men who catcall.
Women are guilty of it too.
Here kitty kitty!
Here, kitty kitty kitty!
I'm gonna take you home, and love you
and pet you and snuggle you
for the rest of our lives.
If you're a person who does this, just know you look like an asshole.
Ok?  It's rude!  It's disrespectful!
You look super immature!
Next time you see someone you find physically attractive
politely ask them out or keep your opinion in your pants.
Otherwise, the next time you catcall
Hey baby!  (kissing noises)
Hey!  I actually have someone I'd like you to meet!
(gasps)
"Mom!?"
I raised you better than this!
No mom!  I'm sorry--it's not what you--
Ah!  Don't "Mom--I'm sorry--me!"
(whimpers)
I'm gonna make you sorry.
(whines)
Thank you for letting me know.
Get home.
Oh...ok.
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay Awesome Gotham.
Thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring today's episode!
Professional design!
Intuitive and easy to use tools!
Regardless of your skill level.
No coding required!
Get a free domain if you sign up for one year!
Start your free trial at Squarespace.com today!
Right now!
Go!